il faut que je sorte d'ici et je
sortirai quoi qu'il arrive
dans la nature il n'y a pas de loi
il faut survivre
ici on m'appelle la fille des marais
l'enfant sauvage qui agrandissent 1
[Musique]
il peut pas rester seul dans les marais
toute ta vie tu veux parler d'accord
j'étais jamais passée par là tu vas pas
être déçu
regardes tu vois là
[Musique]
et je savais depuis longtemps tu sais
que je m'en vais bientôt à l'université
que je ne pourrai compter que sur moi
même
catherine daniel clark est accusé de
meurtre
mademoiselle clark se retrouver ici
parce qu'il est plus facile de faire
porter le chapeau à quelqu'un qui vit à
l'écart
qu'est ce que tu me veux je te trouve
superbe maligne comme tout c'est
pourtant livre oui s'il se retrouve
personne ne lira je le lirai mois
kia il est passé bien pour toi j entends
ça fait quoi qui m'a abandonnée
je sais que vous avez toutes les raisons
du monde de tester ces jours je n'ai
jamais détesté personne c'est eux qui me
détestaient marseillais
vous voulez que je les supplie de me
laisser en vie je refuse que ce soit le
kit est petit pour moi
il faut que je sorte d'ici et je
sortirai qu'il arrive
[Musique]